I'm known in the dj world for
releasing a special perfume that smells good
of course but we say every time I
knew you were there you felt in
the dressing rooms
I know it's not acquired or dj snake
n  10 in the morning I never go out without my
watches I signed a deal with
hublot, which has become my partner, its
brands that I love,
I've been wearing this brand for a long time, and it's super
proud to have become a
brand ambassador  so at the very beginning of my
career but the first big check
i bought myself have a lot of watches
i love watches
surely the one i am wearing at
the moment and transparent
it is a beautiful piece and i wear it a
lot in  this moment but it depends on the
periods of the seasons I always have my
little favorite for 2 3 months always
really liked
porthole because I think it makes you
dress but at the same time it's
pretty cool that you can put it in
any  conditions these super
elegant but at the same time  s you can wear it
in your daily life
regardless of the style of clothing a
photo of my dog is a small thing
it's
legend I like it and when I'm o
tour or on the go etc. it's
lways with me it's  one step
that I'm a pokémon fan is that in
fact when my daughter is this little
ball of fur he was already called
catch where he was very young and and comics and
I thought the name suited him
so well and I like them  kept I
really give it it's my little baby
[Music]
very important that's the key to
having a good day when and pissed off
a kinder when everything is fine
a kinder right now I'm a little on
a diet but  but it's really my
little indulgence
on tour on the plane everywhere
as2 kinder which benefits it I know it's
available everywhere in the world whether in
korea or brazil where it doesn't matter
will always find a kinder at  the airport
and in general we take enough in the
luggage to be  wide super important
and no disappointment
the beats headphones here I do all my
songs with this headphones when I
travel and I compose on the plane
in hotels and it's often
with headphones and on stage also when I
perform  always this one so a
pair of super important white trainers
you can wear in
any conditions
timeless that's puma that's my fear at the
moment
so actually I don't really care
about cleaning them is what I have  a job
that puma and sends me every time lots
of fathers who know that it's my
favorite pair that often I give my pair away
so I sign the pair and throw them
in the public is on tour every
concert a new pair in my  lodge
and I love this series
xala aux pumas so my two passports
here I travel very very often a
French passport and an
Algerian passport always with me it's the
key to everything my life is past trips
from country to country  country continent e  n
continent and meeting people doing
what I like that's
thanks to that that's my life paris
necessarily because it's the house plays
at home so it's always a lot
of love but I like brazil a lot
las vegas also has an important part
in my heart chile also this fort
and asia thailand japan korea
really exceptional public my
perfume super important
I have it everywhere g
my car in my suitcases is super
important to smell good  this perfume from
kuwait
it's a bit rare piece i think i
've known in the dj world to
smell important special which smells good
of course but we say every time i
knew you're there you felt and  106
in the dressing rooms
I know that this guy has been so
dedication to Kuwait for this crazy scent
my computer is what accompanies me
on tour everywhere to do the
shows to compose music on a
trip to the hotel
whatever  in a car and I do
everything everything  my songs on this
computer
I use logic to make my music and
I mix on studio one
I have my habits I go from 8 I don't really
know where someone changes and it's
often when I have my habits
here I stay I stay in my comfort
zone as they say I'm very happy
like that but here everyone
knows my love for
dj snake sunglasses without
sunglasses it's well it's more me what it is  a
little mix between crumbs that I
wear two days with pink
brown
blue shades vintage stuff is all new
I have a little bit of everything I never move without its
embarrassment a lot
solitary vintage with we had
brown smoked tiles it really depends but
with my  moods don't know where I am
it depends on the atmosphere no matter what
always delirium of the sun rises the
soccer ball that's like everyone
the clothes dryer am a football lover that's
when we travel we always have a
ball in  the plane angel and i fa  is with
my friends we often have fun while
waiting for latecomers
but hey we often get yelled at
because we don't really have any rights but
here we pass the time as best we can I
think everyone knows I'm
a big guy  fan of paris saint germain
I grew up in paris I was born in paris
is super hot in front of my
favorite players at the moment low and I
really like who links to the map and of course
neymar marquinhos who is struggling with navas
our goalkeeper  who saved us
not long ago
and I like it a lot for me too by
quoting that the psg people
on the corner the player from dortmund who is
absolutely incredible it's crazy for him
so many players
are in their thirties but  that's generally
me I'm going I'm going to be chauvinistic and I
'm going to talk more about my friends who play
in paris thank you jekyll or for having shared
these little moments with me it was dj
snake see
you very soon I hope ciao